[Música]
y
soy artista imaginar
soy artista imaginar me hace feliz me
hace muy feliz
break free que decía freddie mercury
para mí imaginar es desprenderme de
todas mis certezas para poder alcanzar
otro tipo de universos no decía albert
eisntein que la lógica te lleva de ave
pero la imaginación te lleva a todas
partes la imaginación es muy divertida
es un juego con el que podemos actuar
todos los días la imaginación te da alas
la imaginación para mí es como un hada
interior que tenemos todo y que tenemos
que tratar de activar todos los chats
posibles cada vez que vemos una cosa o
imaginamos una cosa por chorradas que
sean pero siempre están en contacto con
ese hada interior como todos sabéis
robar es darse
darse grandes facilidades de pago para
adquirir objetos entre el público hay
una persona que es una ladrona porque el
otro día robó un millón de euros en un
banco y ha venido aquí a la charla usted
para pasar desapercibido porque quiere
pasarse toda la vida sin trabajar bueno
esto que estoy contando no es verdad
pero como veis la imaginación podemos
hacer cualquier cosa con la imaginación
es infinita
la imaginación hay que tratar de ponerla
fuera del alcance de la monotonía todas
las cosas que vemos están deseando que
le saquemos de la monotonía las cosas
los objetos están cansados aburridos de
ser siempre lo mismo
yo todos los días para mí la imaginación
es un entrenamiento la imaginación es un
músculo que lo podemos entrenar todos
los días todos los días cuando salgo a
la calle me imagino otro tipo de
universos no es ese ascensor del puente
de la salve tal vez se puede convertir
en la cabeza de un cowboy
una que una zanja que está por la calle
pues sí porque no se va a convertir en
una cremallera
unas farolas
que nos encontramos ahí en el euskalduna
esas barras luminosas pueden ser las
espadas de darth vader y obi wan kenobi
e imaginar es muy divertido
para imaginar para ser creativos es muy
importante la empatía y la curiosidad
y es muy importante también recuperar el
cerebro la forma en la que miran los
niños los niños siempre tienen esa
capacidad de sorprendernos con su mirada
por eso son capaces de hacer conexiones
surrealistas y pensar en analogías
metáforas y los niños no tienen un
cerebro condicionado los niños tienen
ese cerebro que sale del mundo de las
categorías porque los adultos todos
vemos con categorías vemos una silla y
una silla para un adulto es un mueble
pero para un niño tiene cuatro patas
tiene un respaldo y le pones dos cuernos
pues igual se puede convertir en un
ciervo esto siempre jugar y dejar que
las cosas que dejar que las cosas nos
impriman yo tengo esa sensación cuando
voy caminando por las cosas o cuando
alguna conversación no pone en el medio
de lo que yo estoy escuchando porque en
mi cerebro condicionado enseguida lo va
a categorizar lo que trato es de dejar
que me imprima que se ha comido en
conclusión de todo esto que he visto
a la vuelta de cada esquina hay
maravillosas cosas que nos están
esperando si tenemos una actitud de
descubrimiento
por ejemplo también vas por la calle y
de repente veo un aparcabicis y me
imagino que es un bloque de notas
cuando fui a londres y vi el gol de él
goldeneye y me imaginé que podría ser
una rueda con un divertido alrededor que
la está dirigiendo no
un día haciendo trekking por el pirineo
oscense la imaginación es muy peligrosa
también porque te llevas un susto de
muerte de repente vio un macizo quizás
no me lo puedo creer o sea no puedo
estar tranquilo aquí en el pequeño
exceso y oscense que vengo a [ __ ] aire
y bueno ya conseguí me encontré a josé
maría aznar
es así la vida
gracias
la imaginación la podemos llevar por
donde queramos seguramente vosotros ivss
ese pico igual lo podéis llevar a otro
mundo
para mí los objetos
son creativamente igual que las personas
todos tenemos hay que ser muy empáticos
todos tenemos cuando vemos a una persona
todos hacemos un cuadro mental de esa
persona esas personas de ese partido
están es el vecino que me habla no me
gusta como me habla porque tiene la
mirada inquisitiva y nunca ocurre nada
porque siempre le meto en este marco
mental ocurre con los familiares con
todo tipo de personas y mientras que no
salgamos de ese marco mental no van a
ocurrir cosas porque no estamos
creando ese territorio para que suceda
algo si pensamos siempre lo mismo que si
en vez de ir directamente tratamos de ir
por otros la buscar otras vías cómo te
llamas
buscar otras situaciones para que
sucedan algo y estar siempre muy
observador es porque la capacidad de
observarse se genera o se se afila
observando cada vez más y mejor
por ejemplo
esto en el mundo de los adultos sería
una legumbre solamente es una legumbre
hemos hecho millones de veces garbanzos
pues un garbanzo qué aburrimiento vamos
a hacer y garbanzos bueno pues haces
garbanzos pero si lo miras con una
actitud de exploradora porque así hay
que mirar para desarrollar la
imaginación se puede convertir en otra
cosa se puede convertir en un niño muy
divertido que nos está enseñando el
culete
podemos esa magdalena que nos comemos a
las mañanas o cuando sea podemos hacer
una representación de la libertad esa
magdalena sea blonda de magdalena que
está siempre constreñida que está
encarcelada que no sabe cómo salir de su
rutina pues vamos a representar la
libertad que yo hago lo que me da la
gana esa bailarina que es feliz y que
estamos creando una historia solamente
con una blonda
el telefonillo que tengo en casa
desde la mente hasta donde esté lleva
veo una forma de un cuerpo sugerente que
me gusta [ __ ] muchas veces es el
telefonillo
y luego también tenemos bueno pues la
jarra con la que le sirvo a mi hija oa
mi mujer cuando no tengo siempre la
sensación que estoy cogiendo siempre un
pajarillo no con el asa
y bueno a mí me divierte mucho hacer
esto porque yo juego una jarra una jarra
no puede ser solamente una jarra la vida
no puede ser tan aburrida a la realidad
hay que poner un poco de ciencia ficción
de imaginación
esa peladura que tiras digo esa peladura
de banana puede ser algo más si le das
un par de vueltas
con esa actitud de siempre de explorador
no me di cuenta que una banana podría
tener miles de conexiones en los
desayunos con mi hija hace cuatro años
yo a las mañanas cuando desayunamos y
con todas las obras que genera el
desayuno o lo que sea una naranja un
asado un poquito de frutos secos
con todas esas obras que van quedando
creamos criaturas imaginarias tenemos un
monstruito luego hacíamos una foto y nos
reíamos quedábamos como un teatrillo
tiene el cual era todo prueba y error y
nos permitíamos equivocarnos cosa que
muchas veces cuando ya eres un
profesional no te permitas equivocarte
porque quieres hacer algo más o menos
que sabes que va a funcionar y yo no voy
a permitir equivocar entonces creamos
unas criaturas iguanas qué maravilla
y fruto de este permitirte equivocarte y
ser un niño a lo grande
pues
en esos desayunos vi que en un cestillo
había una banana y esa banana me sugirió
que tal vez se podría aparecer el
cabello de donald trump y luego si le
pongo un poquito de mortadela
y no sabía si va a quedar bien o mal y
si le pongo un poco porque para la forma
sé cómo lo voy a hacer pues le pongo
unas cartulinas y ya está
y luego me enteré cuando me llaman donde
esté este collage hizo realmente mundial
y ha tenido reconocimientos
internacionales por todas partes por eso
precisamente porque me convertí en un
niño ese es el gran éxito para mí de
este collage no y luego ya me llamó un
tío de nueva york me escribió hoy es lo
que has hecho tú sabías que una banana
en inglés si le pones a un tío una
banana es llamarle alguien banana gt en
inglés es que estás loco y claro yo hay
dijo de soy un genio caro está con estos
índices y además y además
y además claro en inglés mortadela es
balón y en inglés william a
balón y es que esta historia diciendo
tonterías claro con el ga del tío porque
usted es muy grande y no se critique el
[ __ ] pues todo estudie casualidad la
verdad empecé con mi hija esto de
casualidad y no sé y la edad es que fue
muy divertido o sea que yo sin pensarlo
y se cree una imagen que era mucho más
rica de lo que yo lo había ideado
y luego ya con tramos muy bien arriba
[Risas]
con tran dije bueno vamos a hacer a un
primer trabajos a crear un tran which
con queso cheddar y con jamón york vamos
a hacer y luego esa situación de
carnosidad sin alma sin humanidad que
tiene donald trump dije vamos a buscar
una chuleta que me pase tres meses
indagando por supermercados pero yo
salga que hay
chuletas que tiene esa forma no y un día
a día y al cabo de tres meses para mí
fue como como como ver a la virgen maría
digo no no puede ser cierto que algo que
haya imaginado sea cierto yo eso es lo
más alucinante de todo esto que a veces
lo que imaginas se hace realidad
entonces nada les recorte hace un
poquito el perfil y ahí tenemos a don
altar un cacho de carne desprovisto de
humanidad de inteligencia y luego un día
a las dos de la mañana que salía de mi
estudio y un bidón
y ese vídeo pero si se le pongo una
bayeta
le pongo una galleta pero que lo lleve a
casa pero que hace es trayendo estas
basuras a casa por favor bueno vamos a
mantenerlo ahí por lo menos también una
semana de tiempo para ver si llegamos a
hacer la imagen de donald trump y dice
ay a donald tranqui le puse aquí en el
lateral la palabra poison que es poison
tran pues un bidón lleno de veneno con
lo cual
eso es todo lo que tiene que hacer un
collage es que todos los elementos que
utilizas tiene un significado en el
fondo y en la forma nada está hecho al
albur y luego con mis bermudas rojos
pues dije bermudas rojos con esa cara de
cesc colorada y luego ponerla por una
zona y la boca de ese aspecto es tan
deplorable como como suele dar este
personaje no
y esto pues dije bueno pues si podemos
ser un poquito más transgresores
así que
me dije
lo he un día
que hoy en día un calzoncillo y empecé a
explorar lo que cojo un garbanzo y demás
y vi que era muy sencillo era muy
sencillo era plegar una de sus de las
piernas una para arriba dejarla la nariz
y luego buscar un poquito las formas de
su boca y de repente encontrarte con
algo que yo lo había soñado y quiero
hacer algo
bastante loco a ver si es posible y
luego con el historial que tiene este
personaje como todos sabéis juan carlos
de borbón es una persona que es inmortal
porque no puede pasar a mejor vida
entonces sabiendo todo su historial me
apetecía hacer esta imagen
este
yo estoy casado con una argentina
entonces también soy fan de maradona y
dije pues ama a maradona lo voy a hacer
con los alfajores que son los frutos
típicos argentinos con las empanadas y
chorizo y al mismo tiempo de significar
ese personaje que es maradona que
tristemente se devoró a sí mismo no está
con el cuchillo y el tenedor
y bueno al fin y al cabo lo que hacemos
con el collage es dibujar con imágenes
no es necesario saber dibujar tener un
trazo extraordinario pero bueno le pones
ahí los alfajores encima ya tienes el
cabello las empanadas buscas hay sus
referencias y tenemos a diego
y para hacer a nadal un deportista que
soy muy fan suyo
hay que buscar siempre tratar de
sintetizar todos los rasgos de una
persona lo el objetivo siempre de
nuestra profesión es llegar siempre a la
síntesis es lo más difícil llegar a la
esencia en que lo puedo reducir yo a
este personaje tiene se que su boca le
voy a dibujar su ceja como si fuera un
cordón y bueno a veces es muy
sorprendente porque yo mismo me
sorprende a mí mismo y digo creo como
posible que yo a nadal realmente yo
único hacer estas cosas para saber cómo
se hacen porque no tengo ni idea pero el
caso es que me pongo a ellos me pongo
como un niño
y es muy divertido
es tan divertido como hacer al rey
felipe es esto
de abajo al mercado de la ribera lo voy
a hacer con marisco
lo podía haber hecho con otros elementos
pero el marisco tiene un significado las
media de ellas están hechas con percebes
con almejas las hombreras con ostras la
barba con con angulas
[Música]
y bueno la verdad es que ahí tenemos a
felipe es esto
con una cigala lo gracioso de todo esto
es luego ir al mercado y decir solamente
quiero dos langostinos un puñadito de
media hora necesito el langostino para
que me dé la el tamaño de la oreja
entonces soy un personaje bastante loco
me va a comprar toda la pescadería
no solamente quiero esta final a la
cigala que queda perfecta para la nariz
un día pues viendo la frutería las
posibilidades que ofrecen las frutas de
la frutería y que se pueden hacer los
beatles y convertirlo en los beatles
a [ __ ] con borraja con lechuga con
vainas con peras y hacer algo divertido
ahí tenemos a john lennon con hecho su
nariz con una zanahoria
lo que os puedo decir es que para mí la
imaginación es una herramienta que da
sentido a mi vida la imaginación nos
humaniza pero también nos convierte en
dioses creativos de cotidianos de la
rutina podemos convertirnos en seres
crear universos en cualquier momento
el miedo que tenemos los seres humanos
para no crecer es el no explorar el no
experimentar porque si no explora si no
experimentas te repites y si te repites
haces cosas aburridas y si haces cosas
aburridas te aburres y si te aburres te
vas a convertir en un robot
la educación fabrica máquinas que actúan
como hombres y produce hombres que
actúan como máquinas
y yo muchas veces cuando ando por la
calle tengo la sensación que estamos en
una riada de masas uniformes con ese
potencial que tiene el ser humano que es
infinito
hemos dejado nuestro poder en manos de
otras personas empezando por nuestra
imaginación
y estamos metidos en un mundo que le
podríamos dar la vuelta y no estar tan
metidos en la grisura y en la
mediocridad de hacer siempre lo mismo
esto de esta actualidad con el móvil de
alguna manera lo que representa es que
estamos sedientos de imaginación la
imaginación que nosotros podríamos haber
desarrollado y la tenemos atrofiada
estamos sedientos y más de imaginación y
saturados de códigos de barras de
números de
de balances económicos
la televisión la tablet el móvil la
playstation los deportes de masa han
venido a sustituir ese vacío que tenemos
que es el de desarrollar nuestra
imaginación la imágenes ya la tenemos
actualmente a troceada y nuestros
antepasados la tenían mucho más
desarrollada porque ellos veían rastros
de divinidades y de mitos en todo
aquello que posaba en la mirada tenían
una visión mágica que hemos perdido
para avanzar hacia una sociedad mucho
más sabia y más sana creo que tenemos
que revalorizar la imaginación en este
momento el mundo hace crack por todas
partes muchas estructuras se están
creando están caducas por falta de
imaginación creo que tenemos que
recuperar el poder de la imaginación
entre todos para renovar la educación la
política la vida cotidiana
la imaginación el mundo es un lienzo en
el que colgar nuestra imaginación si el
mundo lo miráramos con otros ojos tal
vez tal vez pudiéramos ser más felices a
mi imaginar me hace muy muy feliz ya
vosotros
[Aplausos]